[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hey, everyone.
Thanks for joining us today
for another exciting Talks
at Google in our
Los Angeles office.
Hi to everyone on
the live stream.
Wish you were here with us
today as we welcome Sam Tsui.
Let's go ahead and give
him a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: This is brought to
you today by the Asian Google
network, so if you
want to continue
seeing great events like
this, please reach out to me.
We'll get you
involved in plenty.
All right, without
further ado, here's Sam.
SAM TSUI: Thank you.
Thank you guys.
All right, I'm going to start
with a little cheesy sizzle
reel for those of you who
have not seen a Sam Tsui
video, which that's fine.
I'm not mad at you.
This will give you like a
minute or so of some highlights.
Let's get into full
screen mode here.
You can see how tech
savvy I am already.
Somehow I have made a
career on the internet.
Don't ask me how that happened.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- 1, 2, 3, 4.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- What's up, you guys?
Sam Tsui here.
What's up, guys?
What's up, you guys?
Sam here.
[MUSIC - SAM TSUI, "WILDFIRE"]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SAM TSUI: Thank you.
It's always so much fun going
back and watching old videos
because it's just like this
history of the past eight years
of my life, and I'm like, I
remember what I had for lunch
that day on that shoot.
I remember that director was
being rude to me that day.
I don't know.
It's fun.
It's fun to take a
trip down memory lane.
But thank you guys
for having me.
My name is Sam Tsui.
It's such an honor to be
here talking to you guys.
Googlers are awesome.
You make what I do possible.
You're working on the products
and the platforms that
allow such awesome content
creation and sharing
and communication,
and I truly believe
that platforms like
YouTube and Google
are making the world a smaller
and ultimately better place.
So thank you.
It is an honor to be
talking to you guys today.
I was watching some of
the other talks at Google,
and there are some really
inspiring, cool, you know--
I have nothing necessarily
life-changing to impart to you
guys today, but
hopefully I'll just
tell you a little bit
about my story and sort
of how I got into
this whole world.
And hopefully you
find it interesting
or edifying or useful.
And do be thinking of
questions while I'm
talking because, at the
end, we'll do a little Q&A.
So if there's anything also
you guys at other Google
offices, who are
watching, yeah, I'm
more than happy to talk
to you guys afterward too
and answer whatever questions.
I also know that
this goes online,
so I want to say hi to the
fans that are watching.
Fans nowadays are so amazing
at finding stuff online.
They are just the best
sleuths in the world.
I'll go to an event
and be like, there
was this one really
cool picture that
was taken of me
with these people,
but I'll never find that.
And then I will just, like
a minute after that, go on,
and some fan has found
it on some obscure blog
and made three edits of it.
And I'm like, how
do you do that?
It's an insane skill.
So I know that
there are certainly
a couple of fans
probably watching
this after the fact posted
on the YouTube channel.
So hello, thank
you, Samily member.
I love you.
Yeah, so I figured I would
just take you on a little trip
back in time to how I got
involved in all of this
because I think one
of the awesome things
about having discovered
this crazy world of YouTube
and digital content creation
and the digital space for music
is that everyone who I
have met in that space
has such completely
different stories.
It's such a new platform
and such a new way
of conceiving what a
music career can be
and what an entertainment career
can be that everyone's story
is so interesting and
so unique and different.
So I've loved just getting to
know other creators and sort
of where they've come from, and
that has been really helpful
and sort of just
informing my journey
through this crazy world.
I'm also going to
sing some songs
for you over the course of today
so to keep you entertained.
I know it's lunch hour, so
a little song and dance.
So it all started, I
guess-- my journey--
when my parents met in 1968.
My mom was a high school
music teacher in Iowa,
and my dad was from Hong Kong.
And he came to the States
for college in the '60s,
and especially as
becoming an adult,
I have just gained
such appreciation
for how interesting an
experience that must have been.
He tells stories about how he
was like the only Chinese guy
in the entire state
of Iowa, and he
had to drive two hours to go to
one Asian grocery mart, where
he could get his weird oils and
chili paste to cook his food.
But yeah, especially as
I've become an adult,
I have such insane
respect for that kind
of uprooting your life and
going halfway around the world,
especially back then.
My parents, luckily for me,
got married, got together.
And I really think that
being half Chinese,
being mixed race, especially
as a young person,
very much informed the
person that I became.
And I think all
artists and creators--
it often sort of
has its root in,
when you're a young
person, seeking out
what your identity is.
And I think the more kind
of crises of identity
you have as a kid,
the more likely
you are to become an artist.
So every time you're forced
to confront something
of, you know, I'm mixed race.
So how do how do
I identify myself?
Where do I belong?
Or being LGBT, you know,
these are things that,
as a young person,
force you to really take
a step back and assess yourself
on kind of a macro scale,
which I think,
although that can be
like really crappy and
painful sometimes as a kid,
is a large part of where
my desire to be an artist
and sort of explore the
human experience came from.
So that's my parents.
Flash forward-- many
years later, I was born.
I was always a
really creative kid.
My favorite thing is
there are so many words
used to describe people in this
digital space who do things
like I do--
influencers, YouTubers,
digital stars-- whatever.
And I think, still,
one of my favorite
is creators because,
at the end of the day,
everyone has such different
things that they do.
I have friends who are
beauty vloggers and lifestyle
people and athletes and
gamers, and the common thread
is really our love for
creation and making something.
So as a kid, I made--
oh my gosh--
I was just-- whether it was
writing an original musical
just to put on for my parents
in the living room, or I mean,
I went back home recently and
found I had like published--
by published, I mean printed
on the computer like 20 issues
of "The Tsui Times"--
a newspaper about what
was going on in my life
that no one was going to read.
It's now sitting in
my parent's closet,
but I always had that
instinct to just make
stuff, which I really
had to sort of reach
back and reacquaint myself
with now, as a YouTuber,
as a creator.
But I always knew I
wanted to perform.
As I said, my mom was a
high school music teacher,
so I taught myself to
play piano with her help.
I learned to sing and eventually
to start producing and writing
my own music.
And you know, when I
got into high school,
I started doing choir and the
musicals and all that stuff.
So I always knew that I
wanted to be an entertainer.
I wanted to be a performer.
But my vision of what a music
entertainment career looked
like, at that time, was
totally different from what
it ultimately has turned
out to be because there
was no such thing,
at the time, as sort
of this self-made digital
personality creating
your own content.
Really, as a kid who
wanted to do music,
my idea of what that meant
was I have to get discovered.
You know, I have
to go on auditions,
and I have to make sure I'm
seen by the right people, who
will decide that I am worthy
of being given a platform
and that I'm worthy of the
money being put in to market me
to this and that.
And that's, I think, what
everyone, at the time,
envisioned the path
to becoming a musician
or becoming an entertainer was.
And one of the things that
I think that I'm certainly
so grateful for with
the advent of YouTube
and just the ability to
share content directly
from where it was created
without a middleman to anyone
in the world, truly,
who wants to consume it.
I really ascribe all of
what I have been able to do
and what I've been
lucky enough to be
able to do to that ability.
And I mean, I'll talk
about this further,
but I think, especially
for minorities,
whether ethnic
minorities, LGBT--
anyone who has a unique
different voice that maybe
10 years ago, certainly
if you were, say,
trying to get into
the music industry,
the big wigs might have
said, oh, well, I don't know.
You know, we don't want
to risk putting money
in developing this artist
because he's Asian,
because he's gay,
because he's short--
whatever it might be.
So I think one of the things
that people truly responded to
in, you know, the YouTube
and the digital space
is just the fact that
you don't need someone
to tell you that you are worthy
of your creations being seen,
and you can really
find the people who
want to watch that stuff
and prove yourself,
which is very empowering
for young people
and young artistic people.
You can prove
yourself that there
is an audience for
what you want to do,
and I'm so grateful for that.
So after high school,
I went to college.
I went to Yale, where I
majored, not in music,
but in classical
Greek, which I have not
found to be incredibly useful.
I enjoyed it.
Nowadays, it's basically--
I get to go to the
Getty Villa and seem
like a smart ass
to all my friends
and an annoying know-it-all.
That's basically the only time
that my classics degree factors
into my life, but I
very much enjoyed it.
And it was then in college that
I started this YouTube thing,
which was a completely sort
of novel idea of using this
as a platform to develop a brand
and to launch an entertainment
career.
YouTube was, at the
time, so different,
such a different landscape.
It was more cat videos and home
videos and things like that,
which, hey, I love a cat video.
There's still many cat videos
that I watch on the daily--
no shade to cat videos.
But there just weren't
as many people,
and there were no
precedents of people
who had taken to YouTube
to create quality
content specifically
for that platform
and use that kind of
as a launching pad
to achieve what you want.
So I teamed up with my
friend Kurt Schneider,
who was also at Yale, and who
actually, weirdly, happened
to have grown up down
the street from me.
We went to the same elementary
and middle school as well.
So we knew each other from
back in Philly, got together
at college.
He was interested in production.
I was obviously
interested in just
getting my music seen by as many
people who wanted to see it.
So we figured, hey, this could
be a cool, interesting way
to extend our
reach a little bit.
Obviously, we had no idea
exactly how much it would be.
But yeah, often in interviews,
I'll get asked, oh,
did you know what you-- did
you have this whole master plan
when you first started
posting videos?
And the answer is no.
No one could have
imagined exactly what
the digital space for
music and entertainment
would have become.
But we definitely did it with
the goal of, you know, hey,
I want to be a musician.
I want to do this.
I want to have my voice
heard, so it seemed
like just an interesting
exciting new platform to maybe,
you know, get my work seen by
maybe a couple degrees removed
from people I knew.
So we posted our first videos
and then got maybe 100,
150 views or something.
And at the time,
you're like, OK,
I think I know like 150
people, so these are probably
just the people I know.
This is my immediate circle.
And then those first couple of
videos, watching them grow to,
OK, there's 1,000 people.
All right, that must be
the people I know and like
two or three of each of their
friends and then, as it climbs,
just realizing that it
was getting to a point
where there were
truly people who
had no connection to me
who, for whatever reason,
logged onto this video and
watched it and enjoyed it
and maybe then shared it.
And that was, I remember,
just such an incredible mental
exercise to just imagine people
from all over the world doing
that, and it was so humbling.
And it still is to this day.
So our first viral video was
this Michael Jackson medley,
which was our first
video to hit a million.
And oh my god, that was totally
mind blowing at the time.
I remember we got written up
in the "Yale Daily News"--
a little blurb on the
side being like, sophomore
Sam Tsui and junior Kurt
Schneider have a video.
I think it was even
in the newspaper
when it had 100,000 views, and
we were like, we have made it.
We are in the college newspaper.
This is it.
And the beautiful thing about
the lack of expectations
we initially had was that
everything that happened
was just like such
the crazy windfall.
We eventually got to go
on "Oprah" and "Ellen"
and "World News Tonight" and
started showing up in blogs
and being written up.
And it was such a joy,
and it was so mind-blowing
that simply making something
in your own little dorm
and posting it online could
even have that kind of life
and that kind of traction.
So that was really special.
And then at that
point, we sort of made
the decision to take that and
turn it into something else.
And that's the thing, I think,
that separates sort of one hit
wonder viral video
from the people
who have actually sort of
become content creators.
We were like, look, OK,
there's a power here,
and it's incredible.
And it's thanks to this amazing
platform and amazing fans
around the world, who want
to consume good content.
So yeah, I was like, if we
can do this consistently,
if we can really be smart
about building a brand
and making people
expect and come
to expect exciting, interesting,
creative, different music,
I think we could
have something here.
And the rest was
sort of history.
I'm going to sing
a song for you now.
I've been talking too long.
I'm going to bring up my amazing
guitarist and very good friend
Jason Pitts.
You saw him probably in
several of those little clips
that I played.
[APPLAUSE]
We met a few years ago.
We've been all around
the world together.
It is awesome to get to travel
with a very good friend.
So this first song
I'm going to play
is the first original
song I ever put out.
So the first couple of
years, it was all covers.
Oh, it's actually not
the first original song.
It's the lead single of
my first original album.
I started online with covers
and mash-ups and medleys,
and you know, it was
an interesting leap
because obviously,
in mind, I had always
just wanted to be a musician,
a singer-songwriter, a touring
artist.
And so making the leap from
covers to originals was like,
are people going
to be as invested?
Are they going to be as excited?
And putting out
the first album was
such an incredible experience.
We did a really
successful Kickstarter
and got to make some
awesome music videos
and have been touring with
that album for a while since.
And yeah, it was just
so special to see
that the fans who had loved
the cover and mash-up stuff
were just as excited
about my original stuff.
So this is called
"Make It Up," and I
thought it would be an
appropriate first song too
because it's sort of about not
having really any idea what
you're doing, but
faking your way
through it, which I think anyone
who is in the digital space
knows a little something about.
So this is "Make It Up."
[GUITAR PLAYING]
[MUSIC - SAM TSUI, "MAKE IT UP"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, so that was off
my first original album.
Am I good using this
mic, by the way?
I realized we were
sound checking with it.
Awesome.
Make it up as I go.
So that was off my
first original album.
So after college, I
moved out here to LA
and got an awesome
team and started
looking at how do we turn this
YouTube cover career into what
I wanted, which was to be a
singer-songwriter, a touring
artist, and someone who got
to really go around the world
and share my music with anyone
and everyone who would listen
and found some pleasure in it.
And so that's what the last
several years have been,
have been building
kind of what that is.
And it's really an
interesting spot
to be in, being in this sort
of digital influencer space,
but also sort of, at the same
time, having this music career
that I am pursuing as well.
There's a lot of new
tools that are opened up
by having social platforms.
But there is also-- you have
to sort of be careful about how
you navigate them because,
with so many options and so
many things you can do with
your time and with the tools,
you have to figure
out, obviously,
the right ways to reach the
people that you want to reach.
I want to talk
briefly about the fans
because obviously, in
the trinity of what
makes the world go round, it's
the creators, the platform--
you guys-- and these
fans, who are not only
consuming this
content, but taking
such an active amazing
ownership over it.
And I think that's what
truly is the key to what
makes all of these digital
creators, these influencers,
such a kind of revolution
in entertainment
is actually the fans
giving them that power
and giving them
those opportunities.
One thing that I try to
constantly remind myself
about my fans is that
being a fan, in many ways,
is first and foremost a
form of self-expression.
I think it's easy to sort of
think of fans as these passive
people who are consuming the
content you make and that
everything is kind of
going in one direction,
but I think it's--
not the boy band One
Direction, a single direction.
But I always continue
to remind myself that,
at the end of the day,
when you're someone's fan--
we're all fans of different
artists and different people.
At the end of the
day, by being a fan,
you're really saying
something about yourself.
You're saying, you
know, especially
in the digital age
and the social age,
when you're posting to
Twitter and Instagram
and Facebook about
what you like,
what you're really
saying, on some level,
is this is my identity
that I am building
and I'm projecting to the world.
I'm showing you who I am, and
I care enough about this thing,
or this thing aligns with what
I believe and what I care about
and what I think is
important, so I'm
going to incorporate
that into my own identity
that I'm sharing
out with the world.
So it's incredibly humbling,
and I think it's a big burden,
as a creator, and
as anyone with fans,
to know it's not just this
totally selfish thing of me
making stuff, and you
either like it or you don't.
Once someone has signed
on board and said
that what you do and
your music represents me,
they're constituents in a way.
And I feel obligated
to put out stuff
that continues to
represent them, surprise
them, and interest them, and
be creative and interesting.
But yeah, whenever I'm
feeling kind of in a rut,
or what do I do
creatively, I like
to remind myself
that, yeah, fandom
is a form of self-expression,
and it's something
that I can give
to my fans, who I
call the Samily, which I love.
That was actually fan-generated.
I did a vlog.
I was like, you
know, what is our--
because there have been
a couple different--
some people were saying we're
the Samurais, which I liked.
But I was like, OK, we
need to have a conference
and solidify this.
So I did a vlog, and I was
like, let's vote on what the fan
name should be
called, and we settled
on Samily, which I really love.
It's so perfect because
it's got a couple layers.
It's "Sam" plus "I-L-Y," which
is internet speak for I love
you, so you've already got
the love theme in there--
obviously, a pun
on Sam and family.
And the more I've
been on the platform
and been in this
space, the more true
that rings, that these fan
communities that are created
are really, for a lot of
people, a form of family,
of finding people, who like
the same things as you,
who identify with you and
give you a sense of belonging.
And that's one of
the main things
is I strive to create
in this Samily.
And this sort of
realm of the content
I make is a sense of we're
all in this together.
In a culture that can
become increasingly isolated
with the advent of
technology, I think
it's important to remind
ourselves that it also
has a lot of power to create
communities and create
belonging, which is really,
really important to me.
Another awesome
thing about fans,
which makes them so
important and powerful,
is I think the
constant goes that way,
they express
themselves, and then
there is a return of
a sense of ownership
they have over what I do and
sort of this collective sense
that, the more I'm trying
to go on tour a lot
and put out a ton of videos and
get these cool opportunities,
the fans are very
much a part of that
because, more so than I think
a traditional music artist,
they very tangibly have
a role in everything,
in allowing me to have
those opportunities.
So when I get to
go on tour, open
for Bon Jovi, which I got to
do in Jakarta about a year
ago for 40,000 people.
It was totally crazy.
It was one of the best
experiences of my life.
But every time they get to see
me doing something like that,
it's not just, oh, this person
I really like their music
got to do this.
As fans in the digital
age, they truly
have an ownership
over that success
because it was the
fans sharing the music
and incorporating it into
their life and their world
and their friend group
that is opening these doors
and allowing for it.
So it really is our
collective victory
is every time I get to
do something really cool,
and I think that's
what makes fans
of digital musicians and digital
creators all the more strong
because they're super invested.
And it's a lot harder
to sort of fall out
of that sense of investment
than just sort of passively
like, oh, I like that
song on the radio.
Yeah, I guess I'm a
fan of this person.
But when you've actually
seen the journey from start
to finish, I think
it's impossible
not to have more of a visceral
connection to those people.
One thing I was going to say--
seeing the journey from start
to finish--
one of the best and worst things
about the way that content
creation happens on YouTube--
obviously, it's a volume game.
Going back to make those reels
and stuff, I'm like, oh my god.
I've made so many videos.
There's so much of
me on the internet,
and it's also so
funny that it just
sticks around in a way
that is so crazy to me.
Going to source some of those
clips of the older videos,
I'm like, I haven't
seen this video
in like three years since,
you know, I made it,
and I read the comments,
and this and that.
And then I'll go
back, and I will
see that there's a comment
from an hour ago of being like,
oh, I love this.
So it's interesting
that, while I
think of my progression
and my content creation
in this linear
way, it's like, OK,
three years ago, I was doing
this, and now I'm doing this.
In a way, you're building
kind of this living organism
that it's not totally
linear, and someone
can come in and discover
your stuff from something
you did five years
ago and then see
something you did yesterday
and then see something
you did seven years ago.
And that is both really
cool because, again, it
allows new fans to sort
of take that journey
from the beginning.
This chair is slowly
panning around.
It not only allows fans to take
that journey from the beginning
even if they're getting
in now, but it also--
yeah, every time
you make a video,
it's a new point of
entry for someone else
to then sort of come
on the ride with you.
But it's also, yeah, as an
artist and a creative person,
it's a little
terrifying because there
are some things you made
like a couple of years
ago that you're like,
I've gotten much better.
My skills have improved.
I'm sorry that this was the
first video of mine you saw.
Check out this one I just did.
Yeah, so that stuff--
it sticks around in both a
good and sometimes slightly
mortifying way.
But yeah, the other
the final thing
I want to say about fans
that I have discovered
is their ability to
detect authenticity
in a really crazy way.
Just looking at the
way various different
YouTubers' and creators'
sort of careers have gone--
I think almost always the
most successful people
and the people with the
most and the fiercest fans
are the ones who are
truly themselves,
as trite as that might sound to
say, because fans, especially
nowadays, when you have access
to these vlogs of people who
are being so real and being
exactly who they are in a way
that you didn't necessarily
get to see that much
in entertainment a
handful of years ago--
you didn't see people
being totally real.
I mean, I guess reality
TV started to bring that
into the fore, but the advent
of someone literally just,
without any producers or
writers or anything, just
showing you who they are--
I think it has trained
our young people today,
in a really good way,
to be able to sniff out
when things are not authentic.
And so I think that has
made content creation--
it's a challenge, but
it's a good challenge
to remind ourselves that the
fans will know if you're doing
something that is disingenuous.
One of the things I struggled
with the decision of how
to announce was I got married
last year to my husband Casey.
It was very exciting.
It was awesome.
But when I first
started on YouTube,
I hadn't said anything
about my dating life.
I was a musician,
and at the time,
I wasn't as big on social media.
So I was like, this is
not relevant to what I do.
I just put out music.
And then as the years
went on, I started
to do more vlog style content.
It had become this thing I
just never really talked about,
and I was like this is weird.
I've been out since I
was 18, and I weirdly
felt like I was back
in the closet online,
and I absolutely
hated that, especially
as I started doing more
lifestyle vlog stuff.
So and yet I was
weirdly nervous when
I posted the video, saying,
just, oh, this is my boyfriend.
We got engaged--
this and that, which
obviously was very exciting.
And in my personal life, I
could have cared less about.
I was definitely not in
the closet or anything.
And the moment I
posted that video
and got the responses from that,
I think my content creations
since then has been
off the charts so much.
It just felt so much
better, more real to me,
and I've seen that response
in the fans as well.
I think that the content I've
done since then, especially
the lifestyle
stuff, the reaction
has just been incredible.
And that was really,
really meaningful to me.
Interestingly, you know, there
are some parts of the world,
because YouTube allows you to
build such a global community
of fans, there were
some places in the world
where that is seen as something
a little questionable.
And you know, it's the internet.
I certainly got
comments to that effect.
And for a second,
that got me down.
I was like, OK, you
know, these people
in these countries, where
this is definitely not
as progressive as
it is in America--
that got to me
personally initially.
But then I realized
that there are
gay young people,
LGBT young people,
in those countries,
who are literally
in the midst of that
society, and being
able to be content that they can
consume that that shows exactly
who I am in a really, I hope,
positive and inspiring manner
I think is actually
all the more important.
So every time I saw something
that had hate in it,
it affirmed my
decision more than ever
that it's really important.
As I said before, I
mean, one of the things
I think is most
special about YouTube
is that it gives this platform
to previously disenfranchised
groups and people.
I mean, we've seen
that, in almost
every marginalized
community, a lot of times
you see what you would think
are a disproportionate amount
of YouTube stars from
those communities
because that's the only
outlet that a lot of people
have to see an Asian
person doing pop music.
You look at the top
40 charts today.
There are no Chinese
last names in the top 40
on iTunes or
Billboard, and that's
something that is
really important to me
to change and to hopefully
give young kids a little
more representation in
the music they consume.
OK, I've been talking a lot.
Let's do another song.
This song is called
"Walking Backwards."
It's off my first
album as well, and this
is a song that has meant a
lot to me and a lot of fans
as well.
It's about something
that, as a YouTuber,
you struggle with, as someone
especially in the entertainment
industry, wondering
what you're doing,
feeling like you're sometimes
taking one step forward,
two steps back.
It's called "Walking
Backwards," and it's a song
that a lot of fans
have related to.
[GUITAR PLAYING]
[MUSIC - SAM TSUI, "WALKING
BACKWARDS"]
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Finally, I know I'm
running out of time,
but I just want to
close up with sort
of what I'm working on next
and what's on the horizon.
As I said, it's
sort of navigating
this hybrid new career.
There's no really
guideway for it,
which is both exciting
and a little scary,
of having all these digital
tools at our discretion,
but wanting a music career and
wanting to perform and tour.
So I'm excited to be working
on a new album that is going
to come out later this year.
And the thing I'm
really thrilled about
is that I'm either
producing or co-producing
the whole thing, which was
not true of the first album.
And I think one of the greatest
things about being a content
creator that I never would
have done if I hadn't is
just you're forced to
become a jack of all trades.
And even though I would
have said 10 years ago,
I'm going to be a singer.
I'm going to be an entertainer.
I'm going to be pop star--
yada, yada.
And putting out a
video a week, I've
had to become a great
producer, a great mixer,
a great masterer, a great
video shooter, great editor,
a great marketer-- all this
stuff that, in retrospect, god,
I am so grateful that I had
to learn all those things
because now, when
I create something
like an original album
of my own, it is 100% me,
and I feel that I have the
tools and the vocabulary
to be able to articulate
exactly what I
want to share with my fans.
And I think that's
super important,
and it allows you to then
start to see in artists,
who don't do that often
in the mainstream, who
have these huge teams, and you
can't hear their voice in it.
And as I said, I think
fans are beginning
to be able to sort of start
to read that authenticity.
And so I think it's all the more
important for young artists,
moving forward, to
really take ownership
of your creation and your art.
So I'm really excited
about the album.
It's a little darker, a little
sexier than old Sam Tsui stuff.
So fans, get ready for that.
Brace yourselves.
No, but I'm really
excited about it.
It's like this
super fun, synthy,
throwback vibe that I
literally cannot wait to share.
We just shot the
first music video
for the first single, which
is going to be coming out
ahead of the album.
And I just cannot wait.
This is going up online after.
I would have played a little
bit of it for you guys,
but it's coming out very soon.
So I'm really thrilled about
that, and yeah, I mean,
thank you guys for listening.
I hope this was interesting
or, as I said, edifying.
I think just hearing the
stories of people who are
using this awesome platform--
I always find them to be really
inspiring and interesting.
So yeah, I don't know if
there's time for questions.
I blab on.
Questions-- great, awesome.
SPEAKER: All right, so we
have this awesome Catchbox.
We're going to bounce
it around the room.
Here you go.
SAM TSUI: I want
one of those so bad.
That's so cool.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
SAM TSUI: It works!
AUDIENCE: So you
talked a little bit
about the negative
reaction that came when
you revealed your sexuality.
Could you talk about how you
handle negative reactions just
to the content that you create?
SAM TSUI: Absolutely, I mean,
it's a really easy answer.
You just don't engage.
And I mean, that's the biggest
advice I can give for anyone,
whether or not you're trying
to make a career online.
Even if you're just a
person living your damn life
on social media, just don't
engage with the negative stuff.
And I mean, the amazing
thing about having
fans is that the love
so outweighs the hate,
and when there is hate, like
the moment a bad comment gets
posted, you have like a handful
of fans jumping on that,
responding in kind--
not negatively, but
just pointing out where
there are unnecessary hate.
So yeah, you just
learn to let it go.
And as I said, you learn
that, if someone has something
negative to say
about it, it means
that there are attitudes in the
world that are still messed up.
And so the best way
to combat that is just
by continuing to do exactly
the same thing, I think.
So haters make me
stronger, you know?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SAM TSUI: Thank you.
People talking into that
box-- it's such a neat--
nice.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
SAM TSUI: Hello.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned the
traditional music artists--
they usually have a
persona when they perform,
and your success
depends on being
authentic and figuratively
naked when performing.
It's a--
SAM TSUI: Not literally.
I know I said the
new music is sexy.
It's not that sexy yet, guys.
Don't get excited, fans.
AUDIENCE: So do you
think that exposure
is difficult in this
new life that you have?
SAM TSUI: Absolutely,
I mean, I think
that's one of the big
challenges of navigating it.
As I said, it's kind of
like this hybrid career
because there are some
people who set out explicitly
to be personalities and to
be digital personalities.
So for them, it's
always about, yeah,
what can I do to get
the most eyeballs on me
and let you into my
life to the fullest?
But I went into it
wanting to share
my music, which is not
the same thing as sharing
every moment of my life.
So it's definitely been a
learning process of figuring
out how to best navigate that.
And you know, as I
said, I have found
erring on the side of authentic
and letting people in,
ultimately, I've
found to be good.
But that definitely
wasn't the case at first.
I was hesitant.
I was nervous.
But yeah, I think it does give
a depth to music and to art
when you have a window
into that person's life,
and stuff in the
music, I think, takes
on a new meaning
and understanding
when you have a window
into who that person is
in a multifaceted way--
so ultimately good thing.
It's always going to be tricky.
But yeah, and I'm
figuring it out.
I'm making it up.
AUDIENCE: OK, so kind of
like two questions in one.
SAM TSUI: Bring it on.
AUDIENCE: As you said,
you are making it up.
So I think, especially
for a content creator,
it's important to stay dynamic
and also to stay up to current.
So how is one way, like how do
you incorporate cultural trends
and technology changing
to remain current?
But then also, on
the flipside, how
would you like to see technology
change to kind of suit
you as a creator better?
SAM TSUI: That's a
fantastic question.
Yeah, I think another
one of the big challenges
of being a creator is staying
abreast of everything.
And especially being
a music creator,
there's a lot of stuff.
You know, I'm doing cover
and mash-up content,
so I have to stay aware of
what's happening in the charts.
I'm nominally a social
media personality,
so I have to understand how
those platforms are working.
And when a new one comes
up, how do I use it?
And I'm always
the worst at that.
I'm late to the game.
You know, the actual
interface and algorithms
of YouTube and these platforms
are changing constantly.
So continually being a student
of every facet of what I do
is, I think, critical.
And the moment you
get complacent,
you see that reflected
in the work-- part of why
I, this year, decided to
do a video every Tuesday,
which before, I kind of
had a looser schedule.
And I decided to
do it every Tuesday
because I was like,
you know what?
I have to really force
myself to be regular
and to create this schedule.
And yeah, that was
one thing I did.
I was like, this year,
that's a new thing I'm
going to do because I think
the ways certain algorithms are
working, people
aren't necessarily
seeing all the videos you do.
So I was like, OK, how
can I confront that issue,
where some of my subscribers,
who maybe want to see my stuff,
aren't seeing it?
It's getting lost
in their feeds.
OK, well, one way I can
sort of combat that is by,
if they know it's
coming on Tuesday,
then you're building
an expectation there,
and then there are additional
ways other than just
that little notification.
Now, in their mind,
it's #TsuiTuesday.
So yeah, that's just--
I don't know-- a
little example of just
like a small bit of innovation
to address a problem
and sort of confront that.
In terms of how I would want
to see it increase, I mean,
I think--
well, I love the--
on YouTube, developed this last
year, and I got to beta test
it, is the community tab.
As I said, I think
the main thing
is tools that allow us to build
connection because, you know,
everything in the
digital space is
kind of a double-edged sword.
It is at once alienating
and connecting,
and it's kind of sometimes
confusing of like what it is.
So I think, yeah, tools like
that, that allow you-- you
know, you can watch
a video of mine.
And then in the same realm
and on the same platform,
you can have a discussion
with other people
in a safe space about
that particular video
or about this channel, and
then I can be a part of that.
Tools like that, that
encourage and facilitate
connectivity in a meaningful
way are always welcome.
SPEAKER: Hello, so
we've got some questions
from the online forum.
SAM TSUI: Hello, online people.
SPEAKER: And I was
going to mention
that you've got some YouTube
engineers in the front row
there.
SAM TSUI: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Speak to the
right peeps there.
SAM TSUI: Thank you.
SPEAKER: So Shweta
from Sunnyvale--
this was our number
one voted question--
any plans to visit
or perform at Google,
Mountain View, smiley face?
I think I might--
SAM TSUI: Bring me.
SPEAKER: Yeah?
SAM TSUI: Yeah.
No, I've performed at
a couple Google events.
It's always so much fun.
You guys are great audiences.
Yeah, you're truly awesome.
I would love to.
SPEAKER: Cool.
SAM TSUI: Yeah, and as I
said, I love live performing.
I think one of the things
about doing so many videos is
that-- it's amazing, and I enjoy
it, and I've learned so much,
but it's not the same
as live performance.
I've loved going on
tour around the world
and meeting with fans
around the world.
So you don't have to ask me
twice to ever perform live.
I'm like, come on, Jason, we're
going to go play somewhere.
So yes, I'm coming.
SPEAKER: All right, I guess
you got your answer there.
Next question here from
Lauren in New York--
with cover songs,
it ends up being
so important to do something
different to the original that
adds value.
How do you approach
this, and how do you
push yourself to do new
things with those songs?
SAM TSUI: Absolutely,
that is so important,
especially as the space
has become sort of--
I don't want to say cluttered.
That's a negative
sounding word, but it
has become really
populated of people
doing music online, certainly
more so than when I first
started.
So innovation and being
creative is so key.
A-- by simply being a student,
as I said, of the world
and of music.
I listen to a lot of music
and learn as much as I can
about production.
I mean, honestly, doing cover
music and mash-ups and kind
of the puzzles that those often
entail of either reinventing
a cover or mashing up with
something else or reimagining
it is like the best--
it's like a master
class in pop music.
And anyone who wants to be
a producer or a songwriter--
I think it's like
one of the best ways
to just force yourself
to learn because,
by having to, every week, take a
song that, for whatever reason,
is popular and up on the charts
and deconstruct it, say, OK,
what makes this tick?
Can I reharmonize this?
Can I do this acapella?
Can I do this in a way
that will surprise people?
It really forces
you to kind of look
at the guts of what makes a good
song and then reconstruct it.
So every time I
do that, you know,
I don't see that as, oh, I'm
just doing another cover.
It's like I'm
learning something,
and through that
learning, I think
you kind of surprise yourself.
And yeah, you have
to be committed
to make some videos that maybe
aren't going to be as popular
and be OK with that because
you did something weird.
And I think the amazing
thing about being a creator
and the volume of content we
get to share with our fans,
more so than a
traditional artist,
is that we have a little more
freedom to have a testing
ground, you know what I mean?
A traditional artist might
release music once, you know,
every couple months.
And I am, in a way, putting
out a new piece of music
every week.
And it's a great way to kind of
have a space to learn and see
what works and what doesn't.
And so a lot of the
innovation, I think,
comes from seeing what
people didn't like so much
and it didn't work, but having
the confidence to put that out
there.
And the fans
understand that it's
good to be surprised
even if sometimes you
like the thing they did the
week before a little bit better.
SPEAKER: A question, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can you talk a bit about
your musical influences,
both from your past and from
current contemporary music?
SAM TSUI: Absolutely, I grew
up listening to two things--
musical theater and '80s music.
So I gained from
those two genres
an appreciation for all
things unabashedly just
epic and kind of
ridiculous and earnest.
I mean, that's one
that, when people
ask me to describe like what's
the tone of your songwriting
or whatever and just
your persona in general,
one sort of core of
mine is being earnest.
And I think a lot of
contemporary pop artists,
for a while, it's been
in the other direction.
It's been, who is the coolest
and most aloof and most
unattainable and mysterious?
And obviously, an element of
mystery in music is great,
and it's important.
But I've always been of
kind of the opposite school.
You know, I'm going to
give you all of me on stage
and be totally real and earnest.
And so that's in all my music,
whether it's an uptempo song,
a fun song, a slow song.
I want to tell stories that
feel relatable and real
and not sort of cultivate some
kind of I'm cooler than thou.
So and in terms of music that
is inspiring me a lot right now,
I've been listening to a
lot of Brooklyn synth-pop
because it has that kind
of '80s throwback thing,
and there's a lot of that kind
of fun funk electro finding
its way into the new
music, which again,
now that I'm producing or
co-producing all the stuff,
it's definitely a lot more
me and exactly what I want.
So I'm really
excited about that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you said you like
musical theater?
SAM TSUI: Love it.
AUDIENCE: I have always wanted
you to do musical theater
covers on your channel, and I
can't remember you doing any.
SAM TSUI: I just--
you know, I just did "Beauty
and the Beast" with my husband.
I mean, that's kind of
cheating musical theater.
It's Alan Menken.
Yeah, you know what?
I haven't.
I've gotten some
potential offers and stuff
from Broadway stuff,
which I've always want
to eventually go back
and do that because, when
I was in college, as I said,
I majored in classical Greek,
but I planned on pursuing
music via musical theater.
So I did all the shows at Yale.
And yeah, I know.
I need to.
I really want to go back.
And when the right role
comes around on Broadway,
I'm so there.
AUDIENCE: I was listening
to a "Dear Evan Hansen"
cover of "Waving Through
the Window" the other day.
SAM TSUI: That's a good song.
AUDIENCE: And when I like heard
you were coming, I'm like,
you know, that would probably--
SAM TSUI: I love "Dear
Evan Hansen," yeah.
AUDIENCE: --go really
well with your voice.
SAM TSUI: Yeah, and
especially a lot
of new musical theater
stuff over the last 5,
10 years is basically pop.
You know, it's like very
pop musical theater.
So yeah, OK, I will
take that to heart.
I'll need to do some musical
theater stuff for sure.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Oh, someone
else had a question?
Sorry.
I guess, I mean, I've been
following your YouTube
for a long time now.
SAM TSUI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I've been
wondering, so are your plans
to just become a
big YouTube star
or to become a big pop star,
like someone who's just
on charts, more like, I
guess, as you were saying,
like people are more
impersonal nowadays,
but then at the
same time, you still
want to show like-- you want to
have an Asian presence and more
of an LGBT presence
on the charts.
SAM TSUI: Absolutely, yes
AUDIENCE: So what
are your plans?
SAM TSUI: Absolutely,
well, I think
the amazing thing that
you've been seeing
the last just couple of years
is that it's not necessarily
one or the other.
And I'm definitely not
pursuing one or the other.
I'm not trying to be the
biggest YouTube star ever,
and I'm not trying to be a pop
star who is aloof and doesn't
let people in.
So ideally, I want to have
sort of a hybrid of the two.
You know, look, I want to
scale what I'm doing up.
I want to go to tour for as many
fans around the world as I can.
I want to be on the charts.
I want my music and my message
and, as I said, my visibility
to be as big as it can.
And that's obviously
easier said than done,
but I think with the new
music, I'm on the way to that.
But I think the pop star of
the future is a YouTube star.
You know what I mean?
In the next couple
of years, I don't
think there's going
to be a distinction.
I mean, you see
traditional artists, who
are clamoring to get
sort of a digital life
and get their YouTube channel
up and going because that's
become such an integral part
of the ecosystem of how people
are discovering music, how
people are consuming music.
So yeah, it's to
scale what I'm doing
and hopefully be a part of
the wave of breaking down
the barrier between those two
things and becoming the hybrid.
SPEAKER: All right,
looks like we're at time.
SAM TSUI: Amazing.
SPEAKER: But I want to thank
you so much for visiting us--
SAM TSUI: Thank you.
SPEAKER: --at Google
LA, and I'm sure we all
enjoyed you performing for us.
So let's go ahead and give
him round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
SAM TSUI: Thank you for
having me so much, guys.
Seriously, it was an honor.
And I hope that was interesting.
I hope you guys took
something away from it.
Thank you.